c'est au centre ville de fort-de-france
que sandra merlin conseillère en image a
donné rendez-vous à priscilla la mission
trouver la tenue complète du réveillon
de la saint sylvestre à petit prix alors
le bleu nuit c'est chic je pense qu
accessoiriser sa présence
comment faire si rennes va bien très
vite les regards sont accrochés par de
jolies robes très différentes l'une de
l'autre évènement de rouge pour moi
c'est ma couleur femme fatale avec la
faute
ça va allonger sa silhouette patine
encore plus l'effet de longues jambes le
temps de choisir quelques accessoires
chaussures sacs et bijoux et voilà
priscilla en cabine c'est magnifique
j'aime beaucoup
ah ouais pour le 31 décembre en général
je n'ai pas de loup particulier mais je
prends soin d'euros blanc des robes
longues et là comme c'est au vert c'est
cette fille et ça me plaît franchement
je suis ravi ce sera donc la robe rouge
en prime cette année pas de conflit avec
son banquier pour priscilla le look
couplet n'excède pas les 100 euros la
robe 59 euros les chaussures 20 euros la
minaudière aussi dans le même prix si
les petits accessoires 3 à 4 euros
je voulais du changement pour cette
année on oublie l'éternel robe noire que
tout le monde prend ces voix qui est
classique et un peu plus de couleurs
opposées
donc on est parti sur une robe rouge que
plus facile à accessoiriser aussi il
faut briller donc on cherche les tons
dorés pour oublier comme il faut une
petite minaudière et on a un look final
qui est pas mal
mission accomplie côté sam voyons si la
prouesse peut être répété chez les
hommes c'est giovanni qui recherchent
cette fois une tenue moderne et chic
pour le réveillon alors on va passer à
blanche parce que ça fait sympa
classique et on va l'accessoiriser avec
autre oeil à partir donc de cette
chemise blanche la tenue est vite
trouvée et à la sortie de la cabine
giovanni semble ravi franchement j'adore
beaucoup le pantalon à carreaux cuit il
est magnifique jeu je pouvais le m tous
les jours avec eux au clair petit gilet
une petite cheminée
franchement je trouve que cette tenue
est classe et je peux l'utiliser de
manière décontractée aussi au total
vêtements chaussures et accessoires
auront coûté le plus cher que pour
priscilla 175 euros
mais le shopping masculin est en général
plus cher alors ça reste un très bon
compromis
on a pris des couleurs comme le bordeaux
qui est très tendance actuellement qu on
a associé avec mon pantalon à carreaux
avec des fines rayures bordeaux donc il
ya le rappel et qu'on a terminé avec ses
mocassins bordeaux donc pour finaliser
le tout on a le noeud papillon qui
change de la cravate habituel donc là on
est sous une touche d'originalité
un conseil à retenir homme ou femme
cette année osé la couleur pour les
retardataires il est encore temps de
trouver la tenue pour briller lundi soir